[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
choisir toutes vos idées sorties dans le
département merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro tout de suite le
sommaire devenait apprentis chimistes
astronautes ou scientifique la fête de
la science s'invite à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines atelier
expérience aux expositions ludiques
à découvrir dès ce samedi 30 septembre
notre invité flora tout et nous
dévoilera le programme jusqu'au 21
octobre
c'est une première au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le chorégraphe
aux flèches secteur investit les
planches pour deux représentations
vendredi 29 et samedi 30 septembre le
directeur artistique associé de la
compagnie nous a parlé des thématiques
abordées une réflexion sur la nature
humaine
il y aura de la danse aussi dans notre
rendez-vous junior mélanie poker nous
parlera d'un bal parents enfants
organisée à la ferme de balai bas de
guyancourt mais aussi pour les plus
aventuriers d'un jeu de piste costumés à
saint rémy les chevreuse expositions
concerts et surtout du théâtre jusqu'à
dimanche dès ce vendredi 29 septembre à
19 heures vous êtes attendus pour la 26e
édition du festival de la jeunesse de
l'arast plaisir plusieurs pièces vous
emmène tour à tour dans l'espace dans un
hôpital psychiatrique ou au coeur d'une
soirée bourgeoise organisé par
l'association plaisir oise pour la
promotion du théâtre et du spectacle
vivant ce festival réunira une
quarantaine d'artistes la présidente
nous a donné une partie du programme
c'est un festival qui permet de montrer
toutes les créations ont fait de l'année
par le groupe adultes et jeunes adultes
donc c'est des créations à chaque fois
nouvelle tous les ans est de nouveau
spectacle quand on présente et comme on
aime bien partager un petit peu on a
autour une expo photo qui fait par
d'autres assauts on a invité une
compagnie aussi la kyrielle pour la
deuxième année le samedi on a également
des concerts avec notamment miss kelly
dj cas c'est parce qu'ils sont des
artistes locaux va dire envolez vous
pour l'espace explorer la lumière ou
réaliser des expériences devenait un
vrai scientifique à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 30
septembre au 21 octobre c'est la fête de
la science
et ce ne sont pas les activités qui
manquent sur le territoire flora tout
est chargée d'action culturelle à
l'atelier des sciences va nous aider à
faire le point sur le programme
bonjour flora tout est un jeu alors la
fête de la science pour rappel est un
événement national organisé par le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche depuis 1992 pour
promouvoir la science auprès du grand
public à l'échelle nationale ça commence
du 7 octobre jusqu'au 15 octobre mais à
saint quentin en yvelines vous avez
choisi de prendre un petit peu d'avancé
ça commence dès ce week end avec une
exposition manip à la verrière raconte
moi la lumière alors qu'est ce que c'est
que cette exposition alors c'est une
exposition que vous allez pouvoir
retrouver tout au long de l'année dans
les différentes médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines
donc c'est une exposition avec des
manipulations des expériences pour
découvrir les petits secrets et
scientifique de la lumière que ce soit
l'optique et décrit cité etc
qu'est-ce qu'on pourra retrouver par
exemple de comme manipulation a
d'ailleurs des jeux des manipulations
par exemple sur la vision animal sur
l'électricité
des circuits électriques et c'est donc
la lumière mais aussi la photo ce
week-end ya également des ateliers photo
alors pour ceux qui sont peut-être un
peu plus intéressés par la photo à
voisins le bretonneux ou à elancourt
qu'est ce que c'est alors tout à fait
donc il s'agit d'ateliers arts et
sciences autour des illusions d'optique
est donc là l'atelier s'appelle trompe
l'oeil
donc on est vraiment à la fois sur la
photo mais aussi sur le fait de tromper
notre cerveau de tromper notre oeil
donc les illusions d'optique en fait à
rentrer dans la thématique de la
direction de la culture donc pendant
toute l'année vous allez retrouver dans
les équipements culturels de
l'agglomération beaucoup d'activités
beaucoup d'événements des spectacles des
expositions autour de la tête la
thématique objectif image d'accord et
donc l'objectif justement de cette fête
de la science
qu'est ce que ces serments de pouvoir
échanger autour de tout ce domaine qu'on
connaît peut-être un peu moins
voilà donc c'est en premier lieu de
créer une rencontre entre des
scientifiques et le public de vulgariser
les sciences donc de les présenter de
façon ludique de découvrir des nouveaux
champs scientifiques qu'on connaît pas
forcément que ce soit l'astronomie les
sciences du climat
1 voilà c'est très très large la
géologie la robotique et il y aura un
point d'orgue à cette fête de la science
le village des sciences organisé à la
commanderie des templiers d'elancourt du
13 au 15 octobre
il y aura différents espaces alors que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus tout à
fait donc vous pouvez venir découvrir le
village des sciences qui regroupera 30
stands en trente partenaires
scientifiques que ce soit des
entreprises des associations des
laboratoires de recherche des étudiants
des scientifiques à la retraite ou même
des services de l'agglomération qui
présente ont des expériences des
manipulations des démonstrations vous
pourrez par exemple rencontrer des
robots découvrir le fonctionnement des
hologrammes de la réalité virtuelle
découvrir la géologie observer le
et avec des lunettes et des télescopes
découvrir les illusions d'optique
enfin ce sera très très très très
remplis
on a de quoi faire donc on peut le
rappeur du coup les différents espaces
alors qu'est ce que ça dit à l'image
robotique et un dernier alors qu'est ce
que c'est alors donc pour rester dans la
thématique de l'optique un bien sûr donc
l'optique et les images ensuite une
autre pôle sur la robotique et les
nouvelles technologies ou et puis enfin
un dernier espace sur les sciences
naturelles
l'espace art et science également et les
métiers au coeur de la science un car
c'est la thématique de la région cette
année pour la fête de la science
rencontré des scientifiques découvrir
des formations découvrir des métiers et
peut-être ces images immo limitation au
café imaginer son métier de rêve
heureusement les la science l'espace les
nouvelles technologies c'est un domaine
tu veux toujours rêvé un petit peu quel
que soit son âge
voyez tout à fait c'est pour ça que
c'est vraiment ouvert à tous on va dire
à partir de 6 ans mais aussi bien aux
ados aux adultes aux plus âgés tout le
monde est bienvenu pour pour découvrir
également les nouvelles technologies des
innovations technologiques qu'on ne
connaît pas forcément
et justement dans cet esprit de
rencontre on va on va parler un petit
peu ce que différentes conférences un
qu'ils sont
réalisé en tout cas tout au long de cet
événement il y aura notamment de seine
17 octobre d'autres qu'ils eussent à
villepreux une conférence sur le
tourisme spatial
mais vous en avez d'autres peut-être
nous donner avec des scientifiques oui
pour rester sur la thématique de
l'optique et de la vision nous avons une
conférence sur le glaucome
donc cette maladie oculaire sera
présentée par un professeur un
ophtalmologue qui répondra aux questions
du public
donc c'est un café des sciences et puis
vous pouvez aussi retrouver artistes et
scientifiques autour du lancement de la
résidence poésie et sciences amont des
poètes qui iront dans des laboratoires
du territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
elle m'a parfait tous et rendez vous on
vous casse sont bien notés et sont à
retrouver sur le site internet de saint
quentin en yvelines
merci beaucoup à flora tout et pour tout
ces précisions on le rappelle l'ensemble
de la programmation de la fête de la
science à retrouver sur le site internet
saint quentin en yvelines et on reste à
saint quentin mais pour de la danse
cette fois grand final du chorégraphe
repêche secteur est à découvrir dès ce
vendredi 29 septembre un monde
apocalyptique mise en scène dans un
rythme effréné
le directeur artistique associé bruno
guiot ray nous en dit plus
au micro de mélanie poker
c'est une
pièce à grande échelle on avait décidé
de retourner quelque chose de juste pas
épique
parce que la dernière de la production
s'était trois petites pièces un plus
intime et on avait ce désir de retourner
à quelque chose de grandiose
donc il ya deux actes 1 et de la musique
sur scène il ya un décor c'est la
première fois contre avec un décor et
donc voilà on a passé quatre mois à a
essayé de faire cette nouvelle pièce et
chacun va voir un peu sa version de ce
que de ce que la pièce et mais ça parle
de la mort ça parle de la guerre ça
parle de séparation
ça parle de notre lutte un intérieur et
extérieur c'est une pièce actuelle et
intemporel je pense que c'est un peu
l'histoire de la nature humaine
[Musique]
et empêche aussi aime beaucoup
travailler avec la musique donc il aime
travailler sur sa bande son et toutes
ces choses là mais il aime aussi
beaucoup
1 créée avec musiciens ils pensent que
d'avoir ces personnages là sur scène ne
sont pas juste là pour faire joli ou
parce que c'est bien d'avoir de la
musique live sur scène et que les gens
aiment bien c'est aussi vraiment un
ce sont des caractères qui appartiennent
à cette pièce là et on pourrait pas
faire cette pièce là ce sens il ya
certaines pièces dans le passé on ne
pouvait faire avec ou sans les musiciens
sur scène mais celle là ils font
vraiment partie intégrante du spectacle
[Musique]
c'est le moment de faire le point avec
mélanie poquet pour découvrir deux
nouvelles sorties juniors cette semaine
mélanie vous allez nous parler de danse
pour les parents et les enfants et
d'exploration c'est ça tout à fait c'est
un dimanche 1er octobre charge et
camille il va falloir faire un choix
alors pour le premier rendez vous la
compagnie pernette et la ferme de bel
ébat de guyancourt vous invite à un bal
un bal en trois temps de la danse libre
un moment où la chorégraphe nathalie
pernette même la danse est aussi un
temps de repos pour récupérer en
admirant des danseurs de la compagnie
c'est l'occasion de se faire plaisir et
de partager un moment en famille de
voilà de créer de la complicité entre
les parents et les enfants
ça peut être aussi entre les grands
parents les petits enfants les oncles
les tantes et les neveux et nièces voilà
c'est familial c'est ouvert à tout le
monde n'y a pas de prérequis il faut pas
avoir fait trois quatre ans d'école de
danse municipale pour venir tout le
monde tout le monde peut venir
j'ai envie de dire dès l'âge de 4 5 ans
napper solide aulas a fait poignarder et
jacadi en même temps et nous projeter
dans l'espace social
op
[Musique]
ah oui
alors l'entrée est à 6 euros 80 elle
comprend le bal mais aussi un goûter
traditionnel d'antan pour profiter de
cet après midi rendez vous à la ferme de
bel ébat à 15h alors un autre rendez
vous pour les plus téméraires dimanche
il s'agit d'une chasse au trésor cette
fois oui c'est ça les apprentis
aventuriers devront se rendre au village
seniors orpea saint rémy l'idée de ces
là aussi de faire participer les enfants
les parents et les grands parents
alors jennifer caron la directrice du
centre nous explique la mission a relevé
alors le roi henry 14 a bien caché de
potion magique auquel il tient
énormément mais il a quelques troubles
de la mémoire et
sachant qu'il avait ces troubles de la
mémoire il a dissimulé des indices au
sein de sa cour
l'idée étant au jour les participants de
rencontrer les personnages qui sont
qu'ils font partie de la cour du roi
afin de pouvoir leur soutirer les
informations et d'obtenir tous les
indices et leur permettre de retrouver
ce trésor qui est très bien caché et
donc des défis et des épreuves à réussir
alors parents et grandfonds voix et
grands parents parents à les réviser
votre culture générale
les enfants vous devrez prouver votre
agilité votre adresse tout le monde peut
participer là aussi ces deux là c'est
dès l'âge de 5 ans une participation de
3 personnes 3 euros par personne est
demandée et les fonds seront reversés à
l'association imagine fort margot pensez
à vous inscrire et surtout n'hésitez pas
à vous déguiser puisqu'il y aura un
concours du plus beau déguisement qui
conclura la journée un concours du plus
beau costume merci mélanie pour ses
différentes idées dans son aventure à
vous de choisir des informations pour y
participer s'affiche au bas de votre
écran et on part maintenant sur notre
agenda avec un dernier rendez vous à ne
pas manquer
[Musique]
c'est peut-être le moment de penser à
une nouvelle décoration pour votre
intérieur tv 78 ou fait gagner des
places pour la foire de paris hors série
maison qui se déroule du 27 octobre au 5
novembre à paris expo porte de
versailles
rendez vous sur votre site internet tv
70,15 pour tenter de recevoir deux
invitations de 7,8 loisirs est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis nous espérons que vous avez fait
le plein d'idées sorties pour le
week-end
je vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro et je vous
souhaite un excellent week end
[Musique]